everyone is talking about smoking darts  and all the stuff that's like was from  the East Coast Canada and so much of  that just is frat boy culture in America  too like in the South they're like  speak English nobody you're speaking  Canadian yeah but that never used to be  the case Fred dudes won't be like you  gotta [ __ ] dart on you they never  would say that [ __ ] no I had one friend  in college in my fraternity who was from  Toronto and he would say that and all of  a sudden it was like the funniest thing  ever you know the milk boys spread that  around that's really weird  to go to Oklahoma they're like hey bud  you got a dart on you yeah I'm about to  puff down  yeah about the Polish bird it's  literally like at a m frat guys are like  that like it is a disease it's  everywhere isn't that crazy it is like a  rip a fat piss in the shittery hey  you're from Dallas Texas  rip a piss in the [ __ ] that's a  [ __ ] great that's great that's the  check original Jack says that